Референдум! Желающие проголосовать!
Останній день псевдореферендуму в Донецьку.
Охочих проголосувати шукають на вулиці,
у дворах, стукають до людей у квартири.
Референдум!
Окупаційні адміністрації ще за день до завершення
так званого голосування відзвітували:
явка - рекордна, "референдум відбувся".
При тому, що Росія повністю не контролює
жодну з областей, які прагне до себе приєднати.
А ось так відбувався псевдореферендум
в окупованому Енергодарі.
Голоси за приєднання до Росії
збирали троє людей разом з озброєними військовими.
Так зване голосування на Донеччині, Луганщині,
в окупованих районах Запоріжжя й Херсонщини
тривало п'ять днів.
Організували його всього за чотири дні.
Професор Вільного університету Риги Дмитро Орєшкін
відзначає, що це суперечить
навіть російським законам.
Зрозуміло, що весь референдум
це навіть не кримський референдум,
який був заздалегідь неправовим.
Це погана пародія.
Бо навіть за російськими законами
потрібно, щоб між оголошенням
і проведенням голосування
минуло не менше 60 діб…
Ніяке це не волевиявлення,
це, як кажуть російською, собаче весілля.
Але при цьому вони хочуть зберегти вигляд:
начебто є спостерігачі,
наче є відеоматеріали про те,
як трударі голосують, складаються протоколи.
Це імітаційна модель демократії,
для якої важлива картинка.
На цьому відео з Луганська видно,
що серед учасників псевдореферендуму
небагато чоловіків, тим паче призовного віку.
В українському Генштабі заявили,
що прикриваючись референдумом,
Росія проводить мобілізацію.
Такої ж думки мер окупованого Мелітополя Іван Федоров.
Звісно, ми розуміємо, що це робиться для того,
щоб провести мобілізацію
і забрати наших чоловіків до збройних сил РФ.
Вже четвертий день не пропускають
через Василівку наших мешканців,
чоловіків віком від 18 до 35 років,
а вчора з вечора
перестали пропускати взагалі.
Оголошуючи мобілізацію в Росії,
Володимир Путін підтримав приєднання
окупованих територій до РФ
і пригрозив ядерною зброєю у відповідь
на удари по цим територіям.
Аналітикиня з Бельгії Аманда Пол
вважає, що такі заяви спрямовані насамперед
на внутрішню російську аудиторію.
Він скоріш за все розраховує,
що після фейкових нікчемних референдумів
він зможе "продати" історію про те,
що Захід атакує російську територію.
Це історія для російського населення.
Це абсолютно суперечить тому,
що він заявляв на початку війни -
тоді йшлося про звільнення українців
від злого київського режиму.
Зараз мова йде про порятунок Росії-матінки
від злих українців і Заходу.
Радник голови Офісу президента України
Михайло Подоляк назвав "референдуми"
"пропагандистським шоу",
яке не скасовує необхідності
звільнити захоплені території.
Те, що для Заходу результати
так званого "голосування"
так само не матимуть значення,
визнає Ґустав Ґрессель
з Європейської ради міжнародних відносин.
Захід розуміє, що не можна сприймати
таку анексію як факт.
Не можна піддаватися на погрози Росії,
що вона захищатиме "свої" території.
Їх не визнають,
тому Україна матиме повне право
відвойовувати ці території
чи завдавати ударів по цілям на них.
Про невизнання так званих "референдумів"
заявили навіть партнери Росії
- Сербія і Казахстан.
Таку ж однозначну позицію
зайняли Велика сімка, ЄС і США.
Ми готові спричинити швидкі
й жорсткі економічні наслідки для Росії
у відповідь на те, що зараз бачимо,
і якщо росіяни робитимуть додаткові
кроки для анексії, наша позиція дуже чітка.
Президент Володимир Зеленський
укотре заявив, що псевдореферендуми
закривають можливості для переговорів з Росією
і свідчать про бажання Путіна продовжувати війну.
Аналітик Ґустав Ґрессель
теж дотримується такої думки.
Зараз переговори неможливі навіть для людей,
які підтримували їх,
або подумки вважали, що домовленість
типу "Мінська-3" може все закінчити.
Кремлю не раз говорили,
що переговорів по факту анексії не буде.
У Кремлі погодилися -
дипломатичних домовленостей не буде,
війна закінчиться на полі бою.
Офіційний Київ закликав українців
на окупованих територіях не брати участі
у псевдореферендумах, за можливості - виїжджати.
Адже за добровільну участь
у так званому волевиявленні
за українськими законами
передбачена кримінальна відповідальність.
Аналітикиня Аманда Поль прогнозує,
що людям, які залишилися
на підконтрольних Росії територіях,
не варто чекати на покращення якості життя.
Змушені голосувати за приєднання до Росії,
вони опинилися в ситуації,
коли їм доведеться жити
під владою авторитарного режиму, це по-перше.
Але також вони житимуть
на невизнаних ніким територіях
під контролем Росії,
ізольовані й у скрутних економічних
і соціальних умовах.
У перспективі, вони підписуються
під не надто солодким життям для себе.
За даними британської розвідки,
30 вересня Володимир Путін
планує виступити перед обома палатами російського парламенту.
Очікується, що він офіційно оголосить
про анексію українських територій
за результатами фейкових референдумів.